des annonces pour un nouveau tour de vis
alors que la situation épidémique en
france est critique et la pression
hospitalière élevé dans un discours
solennel le chef de l'état est d'abord
revenu sur ses décisions passées se
dispensant comme à son habitude d'un mea
culpa
là où beaucoup de nos voisins ont décidé
de confirmer
il y a maintenant quatre mois nos
voisins allemands par exemple là où nos
amis italiens en sont à leur quatrième
confinement nous avons aussi par ses
choix collectifs que nous avons fait
gagner des jours précieux de liberté des
semaines d'apprentissage pour nos
enfants
nous avons permis à des centaines de
milliers de travailleurs de garder la
tête hors de l'eau sans jamais perdre le
contrôle de l'épidémie
un discours se voulant rassurant alors
que près de 90 % des lits de réanimation
sont actuellement occupés
le chef de l'état assure que des moyens
supplémentaires seront mobilisés
emmanuel macron promet de porter à dix
mille le nombre de lits en réanimation
dans les prochains jours du côté des
restrictions les mesures déjà en vigueur
dans 19 départements seront étendues à
l'ensemble du territoire obligations
ferme de télétravail et restrictions des
déplacements est la mesure la plus
contraignante concerne elle les écoles
fermées à compter de ce lundi
la semaine prochaine les cours pour les
écoles collèges et lycées se feront à la
maison les deux semaines suivantes soit
à partir du 12 avril
la france entière quelle que soit la
zone de vacances sera placée en vacances
de printemps
la rentrée aura donc lieu pour tous le
26 avril physiquement pour les
maternelles et les primaires à distance
pour les collèges les lycées le 3 mai
les collégiens et les lycéens pourront
retrouver physiquement leur
établissement le cas échéant avec des
jauges adapté avec une tolérance accordé
pour se déplacer en france ce week end
avant la mise en place des nouvelles
restrictions
le chef de l'état a également tenu à
donner un horizon aux français d'ici la
fin de l'été
tous les plus de 18 ans qui le
souhaitent pourront être vaccinés a
réaffirmé le chef de l'état qui a même
esquissé une date possible de retour à
la normale nous allons bâtir entre la mi
mai et le début de l'été un calendrier
de réouverture progressive pour la
culture le sport le loisir
l'événementiel nos cafés et restaurants
ces différentes annonces devrait être
entériné par un vote ce jeudi à
l'assemblée nationale en présence de
jean castex le premier ministre qui
devra à son tour se prêter à l'exercice
du discours devant les deux chambres du
parlement pour détailler ces nouvelles
restrictions gouvernementales